موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تعيين الرئيس الاركان فاليري
جراسي موف قائدا لمجموعه القوات الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وكل من قائد القوات الجويه
سيرجي سوفين وقائد القوات البريه
اوليكساليكوفنائي بين لقائد القوات في
اوكرانيا
جدد مالك مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه يفجيني التاكيد على سيطره قوته
بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه
واضاف انه تم اجلاء المدنيين والقضاء على
القوات الاوكرانيه التي رفضت الاستسلام
في المقابل نفل متحدث باسم قياده عمليات
المنطقه الشرقيه بالجيش الاوكرانيه اين
انسحاب للقوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه
سوليدار
عقد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ونظيره
الياباني يوشيماس هاييشي وزيرا وزيرا
الدفاع الوداد وياسو كازوهامادا مؤتمر
صحفيه في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن جدد
الولايات المتحده بالدفاع عن اليابان بكل
ما اوتيت من قوه بما فيها النوويه وقال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
على ان تشمل معاهده الدفاع المشترك
الهجمات التي تتم عبر الفضاء من جهه اعتبر
وزير الخارجيه اليابانيه تحديا
الاستراتيجيا غير مسبوق
وقال رئيس الوزراء الياباني ان بلاده
تستعد لمضاعفه ميزايتها العسكريه بما
يجعلها صاحبه ثالث اكبر ميزانيه عسكريه في
العالم بحلول عام 2027 واضاف ان بيئه
الامن في العالم تمر بتغيير كبير وانما
يحدث في اوكرانيا اليوم قد تشهده اسيا غدا
ووقع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
مع نظيره الياباني
على التعاون الدفاعيه الامنيه بين البلديه
وتسمح بنشر قوات كل منهما في كلا البلددين
قالت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه
ان حركه الطيران الطبيعيه سالفت بشكل
تدريجيا في انحاء الولايات المتحده وقد
الغيت اكثر من الف رحله طيران داخليه
وخارجيه وقالت اداره الطيران الى
التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى تلف احد ملفات
بيانات الاشعار الجوي وقالت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض انه لا يوجد دليل حتى الان
على ان الخلل كان ناجما عن نجوم سبراني
اقتصاد البلاد في خطر واشار الى ان الحل
يكون في برنامج عاجل للانقاذ من جانبه جدد
الرئيس سعيد اتهاماته لاطراف لم يسممها
بالوقوف وراء نقص عدد من المواد الاساسيه
في الاسواق بهدف تاجيل الاوضاع قال العياش
الهمام مناسق هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه
المعزولين ووزير حقوق الانسان التونسي
السابق ان اسس الدوله باتت مهدده بعد ان
الغي الرئيس السلطات الاخرى واضاف الهمام
في اختصار السابق مع الجزيره ان جزيره
العدل لفقت ملفات بلا سند لازاله القضاء
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]